survivre bonjour merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation merci de vous installez
vous êtes président du modem vous êtes
maire de pau
alors première question si vous étiez
députés aujourd'hui vous auriez un choix
à faire voteriez-vous cette motion de
censure non je ne voterai pas la motion
de censure parce qu on est vraiment dans
cette ventre tous en héros position
ordaz grave on est vraiment dans un
système qui est qui nous
tient la tête à l'envers
mêmes qui marche sur la tête parce que
voilà une politique une loi on peut pas
dire que ce soit la loi du siècle comme
a dit françois hollande peut pas dire
que ce soit une loi exceptionnelle on ne
peut pas dire qu'elle bouleverse
la situation économique du pays mais
tout le monde s'accorde à dire allez les
70% du ceux qui ont participé à la
discussion au fond de mamie pense que la
loi va plutôt dans le bon sens et puis
voilà que la majorité refuse son soutien
à cette loi parce que elle va trop dans
le sens de l'opposition et voilà que
l'opposition qu'à une loi qui va plutôt
dans son sens décident de voter une
motion de censure sans sans aucune
chance de succès mais est ce que vous
voyez à quel point les choses sont
devenues
caricaturalement absurde pour environ
vous connaissez la vème république
l'esprit de la motion de censure ce
n'est plus de se prononcer sur la loi
macron mais c'est de se prononcer
globalement sur la politique du
gouvernement non monsieur c'est l'esprit
de la cinquième patrick chêne le
l'esprit de du texte c'est la loi est
réputé adopté sauf si une motion de
censure est adoptée c'est vrai c'est ça
le texas et le texte je vais dire ça va
naître c'est le texte de la constitution
et donc quand vous faites adopter une
motion de censure c'est pour empêcher la
loi d'être
mises en application il ya quand même
d'être dans ses politiques généralement
bien écouter pour une fois à la pensée
que vous les voyez pour une fois qu' il
y a dans le dans le dans l'évolution du
paysage politique
c'est un mouvement qui est un mouvement
qui permet de rapprocher les points de
vue sur l'avenir et de dire pour
simplifier l'économie a besoin de plus
de liberté si on veut créer des emplois
alors on prend des secteurs qui sont pas
tous bien inspirés mais vous voyez bien
que autorisés à faire des voyages en
autocar dans notre pays pour moi je ne
soupçonnais pas qu'il fallait une loi
pour faire ça ou bien amélioré les
prud'hommes pour que les décisions ne
traîne pas pendant des années ou bien
s'intéresser à l'actionnariat salarié
pour que ce soit plus attractif vous
voyez bien que tout cela va plutôt dans
le sens d'une dune au fonds de plus de
liberté pour l'heure pour l'économie et
on en à extrêmement besoin tout le monde
les syndicats 1 votre influence les avis
du modem allant jusqu'à lui dit global
aujourd'hui vont tous voter cette
censure et bien oui parce qu'il ya des
comportements qui sont des comportements
de groupe 1 pour ne pas dire grégaire
parce que on vote comme ça parce que ça
se fait comme ça mais vous voyez bien
qu'à force d'avoir des comportements
caricature comme ça la politique
française dans son ensemble la
démocratie française dans son ensemble
elle devient aux yeux des gens caduque
et alors ils vont chercher des gens
capables de renverser la table il ya un
lien direct de cause à effet entre
l'absurdité des comportements ou des
pratiques politiques on va dire ça comme
ça deux largement commandé par sinon nos
institutions nous du moins aux règles le
le le
il ya un lien de cause à effet direct
entre ces pratiques et les votes qui
sont des votes par exemple en direction
du front national bien que le front
national n'est aucune solution pour le
pays à mes yeux et même pire donc alors
deuxième question que m'inspirent votre
position est ce que les lignes peuvent
bouger parce que ce que vous souhaitez
en effet on le voit un peu comme le
dirait peut-être manuel valls hier où
emmanuel macron à l'assemblée s'est il
ya ceux qui sont pour l'immobilisme et
ceux qui veulent bouger vos métiers dans
le monde ce qui veut bouger est-ce que
vous pensez que ça et on peut parler
aussi de la position vis-à-vis de
l'europe puisqu'on voit dans les partis
aujourd'hui organisés sur l'europe
personne n'est d'accord y'a pas de ligne
précise et sur ces sept longs macron
c'est encore plus criant est ce que les
lignes peuvent bouger puisque vous le
dit autrement on va tout droit vers
peut-être les extrêmes ce que vous ne
souhaitez pas est ce que les lignes
peuvent réellement bougé juppé bayrou
est ce que c'est une réalité est-ce
qu'on peut aller plus loin vers le
centre vers la droite de la gauche
pardon je suis persuadé qu'il ya un
grand courant central dans le pays qui
est la seule alternative possible à ces
décomposition que vous décrivez et
auquel nous assistons ce grand courant
central il ne demande qu'à exister alors
ça dépend j'écoutais par exemple le
maire de lyon gérard collomb ce matin il
dit à sa manière exactement ce que je
dis est ce que nous sommes vienne chemin
ne laisse que nous sommes un certain
nombre évidemment à constater et a
affirmé alors
il ya une clé tout ça cette clé elle est
entre les mains du président de la
république françois hollande a été élu
en s'engageant à changer les règles du
jeu
et a changé en particulier le mode de
scrutin absurde dans lequel nous sommes
et qui est un danger profond parce que à
force de deux de s'en remettre au fait
majoritaire un jour le fait majoritaire
donnera le pouvoir à ce qu'on prétendait
éviter parce que c'est comme un barrage
vous savez un jour il ya une goutte
d'eau de plus qui fait déborder
le vin et qui fait déborder le barrage
et si les bords de pages barrage casse
tout ça c'est pour moi une très grande
imprudence alors le président de la
république hélas dans sa dernière
conférence de presse il a parlé de
l'ukraine c'était bien mais il dit je ne
bougerai plus rien si j'ai pas un accord
général mais son travail c'est de bouger
sa responsabilité la responsabilité d'un
chef de l'état la responsabilité de
quelqu'un qui a
le pays à conduire sa responsabilité
c'est de dire voilà ce qui ne va pas je
vous propose donc complète en partie bon
il ya il ya beaucoup de solutions
possibles et après des alliances langage
c'est ce qui vous permettra il faut des
alliances il faut que vous mesuriez deux
choses premièrement que tous les pays
européens continentaux sans exception en
dehors de la france ont tous le même
règle électorale c'est à dire que quand
vous représentez un certain nombre de
citoyens bah vous avez des représentants
dans le débat parlementaire ce qui est
vraiment la moindre des choses on a
aujourd'hui 50 % des français si vous
additionnez l'extrême droite l'extrême
gauche et le centre qui sont 100
représentations auprès oui pour ainsi
dire sans représentation bah ça peut pas
aller 2-2 quel droit les autres 50%
aurait-il tous les sièges leur voix ne
vaut pas plus alors vous parlez danse
c'est comme si
quart d'once à une seconde en tête c'est
comme si
ces gens là c'est 50% de français
n'avaient pas le droit de vote et de
quel droit le rang lèvres t'on le droit
de vote dont seuls sas c'est là du
trésor a dit les miens ce camp là sans
se sont absurdes il faut le constater et
se poser la question de leur changement
voilà pour ce premier point ou pas
deuxièmement c'est la seule possibilité
ce changement de règle pour que puisse
se faire des majorités d'idées c'est à
dire qu'au fond quand on est d'accord on
puisse trouver des ententes je parlais
hier avec michel barnier il m'a dit mais
au parlement européen c'est ce que j'ai
fait pendant tout le temps que j'étais
commissaire et c'est ce que tous les
parlementaires européens constaté savent
on fait des ententes pour pouvoir à 2 td
texte et en france nous avons la chance
que l'élection du président de la
république au suffrage universel donne à
tous à quelqu'un qui peut orienter le
débat
généralement quand on parle de
proportionnelle notamment total on dit
mais ça a échoué à la fin de la
quatrième république c'est pour ça
justement
25e la vème république qu'est ce que
c'est
dans le discours de bayeux que vous
savez au lendemain de la guerre de
gaulle est tenue pour dire sa vision des
institutions dans le dos alors qu'il
commençait sa traversée du désert comme
on dit dans disco de bailleul général de
gaulle y dit quelque chose de simple il
dit le gouvernement ne procédera plus de
marchandage parlementaire il procèdera
du président de la république et lui
s'étaient pas encore le suffrage
universel par les france n2
c'est ça le choix on a la chance d'avoir
une élection directe du président de la
république qui peut permettre de donner
une colonne vertébrale à tout le système
c'est pourquoi c'est pas la 4ème
république et c'est ce qui se passe dans
tous les autres pays européens et sur le
législatif on en revient à la
proportionnelle pour justement la
représentation vous souhaitez vous
parler d'alliance permettez moi une
dernière phrase si on réfléchit un peu
on s'apercevra qu'il y à là la seule
garantie contre une éruption de
d'extrémisme quel qu'il soit au pouvoir
parce que si vous n'y fait pas attention
le scrutin majoritaire va accentuer un
jour
là la vague extrémistes et la
proportionnelle nécessite oblige aux
unions et au aux accords
quand on entend alain juppé qui évoque
un accord possible avec vous qui se fait
siffler à l'ump quelques il serait nommé
quelle serait l'alternative quel accord
pour espère toujours que le les sifflets
n'ont aucune importance parce que les
sifflets les sifflets c'est le langage
de la bêtise et franchement on va pas
s'arrêter à ce genre de choses ça passe
j'ai souvenir que nicolas sarkozy a été
fortement sifflé par les mêmes autrefois
donc non c'est pas ça l'important
l'important votre avenir je vais
sur votre congé pour l'amender si c'est
normal un sort similaire
c'est la situation
pardon dans laquelle nous parlons de
quelle est votre position par rapport à
ça il ya quand même 2017 car et je sais
bien que c'est pas le jour dans une
grande position définitive mais quel est
votre tendance comment voyez-vous très
simple
si elle à juppé qu'a choisi le mécanisme
de la primaire moi je suis un peu plus
réservé par rapport aux mécanismes de la
primaire mais si alain juppé est choisi
je n'aurai aucun mal je crois à trouver
avec lui un accord favorable pour que ce
se soit solide pour que l'ensemble soit
un ensemble solide parce que alain juppé
à me semble-t-il les qualités
nécessaires pour le faire et donc aussi
à nicolas sarkozy ait choisi par la
primaire eh bien nous serons libres et
nous verrons ce que nous faisons le vous
voyez bien pourquoi vous dites
actuellement au zinc droit de pardon
c'est si vous voulez une union au
premier tour pour éviter d'absence au
deuxième tour et pourquoi pas candidats
ps face à marine le pen
alain juppé est l'homme de la situation
pour sa vie avec le santos croit que ce
qu'il faut c'est une démarche qui soit
une démarche de rassemblement et de
volonté du pays qu'ils soient pas une
démarche de monter les uns contre les
autres parce que si vous monter les uns
contre les autres vous êtes sûr que vous
pouvez pas redresser le pays et ceci est
vrai dans une entreprise dans une
association dans une famille et c'est
vrai évidemment pour un ensemble
national c'est vrai pour une ville vous
êtes votre mission quand vous êtes à la
tête ou en responsabilité c'est que les
gens puissent travailler ensemble
puissent s'estimer puis se réfléchir
puisse en tout cas ne pas se regarder
comme des ennemis irréductibles alors
qu'ils sont concitoyens et qu'ils
réfléchissent au contraire en se sentant
coresponsable de l'avenir du pays si
vous êtes un européen convaincu en ce
moment la grèce provoque de fortes
tensions avec l'europe ya des voix qui
commencent à s'élever en disant pourquoi
l'europe ne se passerait pas de la grèce
finalement pourquoi la grèce ne
sortirait pas de l'euro qu'en pensez
vous dont je je
je suis très sceptiques sur les
promesses notamment de dire je cois je
suis très sceptique par sur les
promesses qui ont été faites par syriza
le nouveau gouvernement grec
très sceptique parce que je pense qu'on
a fait croire aux grecs que l'impossible
étaient possibles alors c'est bien
d'avoir des idéaux et des rêves et c'est
vrai que les grecs avaient été
maltraités mais la situation aujourd'hui
c'est que vous avez beaucoup de pays qui
ont montré de la solidarité avec la
grèce et qui serait déstabilisée eux
même si la grèce ne respectaient pas
alors ma question à dans les grandes
ligues c'est en tout cas on va voir ce
soir ce qui va se passer pour moi je
n'invente sur les types de voix en exclu
bages que je je pense que c'est une des
issues possibles
hélas
trois fois hélas c'est une des issues
possibles de la situation dans laquelle
nous nous trouvons parce que vous ne
pouvez pas lorsque vous êtes endettés
par dessus la tête dire écoutez je vais
me lancer dans des dépenses nouvelles et
je vais au contraire
demandé des crédits nouveaux ce jour là
ce qui vous prêtent ne le font pas et si
cette idée de la sortie de la crise est
là laurence la france on risque dans
cette affaire plus de 40 milliards mais
vous ne craignez pas l'effet domino la
grèce sort on s'aperçoit que finalement
avec l'aide de la russie pourquoi pas
ascenseurs me mets tous essaient de
l'union portugal sur les nano mais je
joue ça c'est des blacks vous croyez que
que vous croyez que la grèce pourrait
s'en sortir sans avoir des dommages
extrêmement lourd pourrait sortir de
l'euro sans avoir des dommages
extrêmement lourd mais vous l'envisagez
tout de même je pense que c'est que
c'est un risque oui quand on fait croire
aux peuples des choses impossibles il se
produit hélas des conséquences souvent
dangereuses ou déstabilisante un dernier
mohamed tazir dans sa revue de presse
quotidienne régionale parlait du fait
qu'on armait ou pas les polices locales
vous êtes un maire d'une ville
importante comme pau quelle est votre
position très rapidement ben j'ai décidé
que la police municipale à pau aurait
des flashballs et des teaser c'est à
dire des armes non létales comme on dit
qui peuvent pas tuer
parce que notamment les brigades de nuit
que nous allons mettre en place pour
qu'ils aient un sentiment est une
réalité de sécurité bon ben il faut il
faut caser de quoi ne pas avoir peur
mais je ne suis pas pour les armes
létales je ne suis pas pour les pour les
armes à feu merci françois bayrou nous
avons rendu visite ce matin je rappelle
que vous êtes maire de pau évidemment
président du modem et qu'on commence à y
voir un peu plus clair sur votre
positionnement pour les mois à venir
extrêmement clair merci vous êtes une
belle journée